hey buddy nice ass oh you got to be
kidding me
oh you gotta be kidding why oh you gotta
be kidding me
you get back here [ __ ] you you're gonna
die tonight you and your talk chest in
your lovely what
you look good sailor smack good job
let's go
oh what's that over there kids nice ass
there who next face
- how about you the other toxins good
job sorry I'm normal normal normal
normal I do not want to grope this shark
can no no just a normal human being
grinding on I just beamed my kid in the
back of the head with a gallon of milk
regular normal dad stuff I know you have
camouflage but I didn't know is that
good
[Music]
but you care for a dance did I wanna go
over there go over there hello no raise
arm okay thank you for doing that
pump it up okay you like how I pump it
baby you like how I pump this fish
[Music]
rewind that never happened hey yeah this
is definitely the first time I ever did
this one
[Music]
there we go all right all right okay
think of the kids think of the kids just
think of the cake let's just keep the
kids in line it's gonna be okay think of
the kids
it's gonna be okay okay